when you walk on a muddy street you may  see paw prints right from a dog or a cat  but i gotta say i've never seen prints  like this before paul baker stumbled  upon dinosaur tracks in a dried up  riverbed at dinosaur valley state park  in north central texas last week look at  these bad boy tracks can you imagine  baker is part of a non-profit that works  with the national natural landmark which  is known for  113 million year old dinosaur tracks  that are embedded in limestone now these  prints had never been seen before texas  parks and wildlife told local media the  tracks will be buried again by the river  once the extreme drought subsides and  the area that was hit with torrential  rain this week is going to cover it up  volunteers make sure to document the  tracks before they disappeared  right  do they know what type of dinosaur uh  yeah but i couldn't pronounce it  it's a big one it was a large big boy